[Music]
makes email from FX guide.com for Wired
it's one thing to create something that
is computer-generated and looks
completely photo-real it's another when
there is literally no reference for that
because the character is completely
invented in Game of Thrones Season 3
picks a mando in Germany were tasked
with the problem of producing some
realistic flying adolescent dragons now
the show has such high production values
that the team set out to produce
something that was not only cool but
physically plausible to do this concept
designs were developed that accounted
for the adolescent proportions of the
Dragons who had actually grown since
season 2 the bigger challenge though was
making them fly believably just how do
teenage dragons fly clearly that doesn't
exist a fire-breathing mammal or some
kind of flying winged creature that the
team put reference so they had to set
out to work out for example the lift to
wing ratios with digital wind tunnel
simulations they also had to do water
simulations and studied a variety of
reference material in fact they ended up
with a mix of an eagle and a bat the
eagle is used more for soaring gliding
motion and more of a bat kind of motion
when the dragons were taking off this
also had to be tempered of course with
the fact that dragons are not yet fully
grown so they needed to have a young
kind of energetic and slightly awkward
appearance
but the most complicated part was really
the animation that hovering mode was
always tricky because it shouldn't look
too stable and so we have but we have to
have this wing flaps big enough to keep
the body in position and to find that
right amount of speeds and doing flap
size was very important for us to keep
it believable the final result is by the
fan-favorite and something that really
sits very well with the immersive world
of Game of Thrones
of course animation only partly solved
the problem to fully solve it they had
to get very accurate lighting and really
interesting interaction between the
actors and the digital characters so
every day is a very traditional approach
so they had a stuffy on set so three
stuff is follow the trigons it was a
great help for the actors to have real
puppet creature their standing in front
of them to to get an idea of what how it
will look at the end this was taken out
of frame and then the shot was done with
a tennis ball on the stake just
mimicking what the dragon might do at
the end so she took us give it an
eyeline the final solution delivered on
the realism and the quality of feature
film visual effects but inside the
constraints and timescales of episodic
television well if you want to learn
more about the visual effects secrets
behind some of the biggest blockbuster
productions be sure to subscribe
I'm Mike Seymour for Wired
[Music]